cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film marie francine avec valérie
lemercier patrick timsit et hélène
vincent
qu'est ce que tu as 50 ans trouviez pour
son mari de trop dans son boulot marie
francine doit retourner vivre chez ses
parents à 50 ans infantiliser par eux
c'est pourtant dans la petite boutique
de cigarettes électroniques qu'ils vont
lui faire tenir qu'elle va enfin
rencontrer miguel migs sans oser le lui
avouer est exactement dans la même
situation qu'elle
comment vont faire ces deux là pour
abriter leur nouvel amour sans maison là
est la question
avec en toile de fond le fameux cap de
la cinquantaine
cette comédie romantique et
attendrissante se révèle à la fois douce
et touchante on tombe vite sous le
charme de son héroïne incarnée par
valérie lemercier comme sous celui de
son nouvel amoureux interprété par un
patrick timsit inattendue en cuisiniers
séducteur le thème du retour des adultes
chez leurs parents est ici traitée avec
beaucoup de douceur et un peu de
burlesque timsit surprend en embrassant
un registre bien veillant aux antipodes
de son cynisme habituel marie francine
le nouveau film de valérie lemercier
marie francine est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret